well the clark county public
administrator is in jail facing a murder
charge and will not have the chance to
post bail the politician accused of
killing a longtime las vegas journalist
the eight news now investigators have
the latest evidence in this case we
start with vanessa murphy at court
a judge pointing to evidence in this
case like dna how investigative
journalist jeff gehrman appears to have
fought for his life and how it appears
robert tellis waited for him before the
attack quite chilling as well the
defendant's dna is alleged to have been
recovered from the hands of
the victim clark county public
administrator robert tellis is being
held without bail as he faces an open
murder charge the victim longtime review
journal investigative journalist jeff
gearman who exposed problems under the
leadership of telus in court wednesday
las vegas justice court judge alana lee
graham noting his shoes hat and vehicle
matching video from the crime scene his
cell phone activity terminated before
during and after the murder and
defensive wounds found on german no
comment from telus when we tried to talk
to him wednesday after he was questioned
by police did you commit this murder
did you do this tell us anything a
couple of hours later when police tried
arresting tell us he refused to come out
which led to a neighborhood lockdown
clark county district attorney steve
wolfson says police needed a solid case
and dna results were a key part was
there any way he could be kept with
police to avoid that barricade not under
the law
there are rules and laws in place which
say that a person can be detained for a
certain period of time this was a very
fluid dynamic
a few hours a public defender tells me
tellis is hiring a private attorney his
next court date is set for tuesday
reporting at the regional justice center
in downtown las vegas vanessa murphy 8
news now